No.
All right.
Before I get to what's going on in the
world this week,
I want to once again thank all of you
who support what we do here on the Rubin
report.
I'm thrilled to finally be able to show
you our brand new home studio today.
It took a tremendous amount of blood,
sweat,
tears,
and yeah,
even money to build it and we simply
could not have done it without you.
Of course,
the main thanks goes out to all of you
who donate monthly to the show on
Patrion.
As you guys give us the budget to create
content as we see fit with no
executives,
bosses,
or middlemen between me and you beyond
our patrons.
I also want to thank all of those who
have given one time donations on paypal
as well as to all of you who watch light
comment on and share our videos with our
new home studio.
We can fully expand on everything we've
been building here,
including more shows,
longer interviews,
and new segments.
I truly believe that the ideas of
classical liberalism,
logic,
reason,
and individual liberty are the only
solution to the authoritarian and
extremist problems we're seeing all over
the world right now.
I'll continue to have conversations with
people I both agree with and disagree
with and just as importantly,
I'll continue to listen to you from my
Patriot on one on one chats to group
Google hangouts to emails and yeah,
even twitter,
you guys consistently amaze me at your
insight and desire for truth.
My commute is now just 10 steps down the
hall from my bedroom and I promised to
use that new found time to make this
show even better than before.
You've truly helped my dreams become a
reality and somehow we're right back at
the beginning.
In the course of the month that we were
building this studio,
basically a million things happened.
I'm not sure if you've heard about this,
but we had an election in the United
States and Donald Trump.
Yeah,
Donald Trump is now the president elect.
While most of the media seemed to be
completely blindsided by the results,
I can honestly say that I wasn't.
I talked to and listen to people like
Scott Adams,
Milo Yiannopoulos,
and Mike Cernovich,
and whether I agreed with them or not,
I realized that there was a real
political movement behind their words.
When you couple this reality with
moderate liberals and moderate
conservatives who are sick of identity
politics and outrage culture,
trump winning actually seems kind of
obvious in hindsight.
I'm trying to do my best not to judge
trump's actions until he's actually an
office because until then,
everything people are saying are just
guesses and conjecture.
As I said in my direct message right
after the election,
I'll be the first to hold trump,
speak to the fire once he's in office,
but the simple fact is that he's the
president elect now and we've got to
give him a chance.
That's the rub of democracy.
Your team doesn't always win,
but you can't burn down the system just
because you were on the losing end this
time,
regardless of whether you hate or love
trump,
there's no doubt that something good did
come out of this election.
People seem to be engaged in a whole new
way.
People are talking politics,
fighting for what they believe in
getting involved in the conversation,
maybe even more now than when Obama ran
for the first time back in 2008 I think
we're going to get a whole new crop of
political leaders out of this chaos and
I hope some new political movements as
well as I've been saying for a year now,
if you're an old school liberal than an
old school,
conservative is no longer your enemy.
I really think a new center can arise
from this and if trump is smart,
he can actually make that happen.
Trump is a populist and that means he
wants to be popular.
Most of us are socially liberal and
fiscally conservative.
Most of us are not the alt right or the
regressive left.
Most of us don't care what you do in the
privacy of your own home and we want
government to take less instead of
giving more.
I think we can actually push trump
towards these ideals,
but if not,
then maybe we'll just have to create our
own movement to do so.
Actually,
maybe that's already begun with all this
in mind.
I've got the perfect guest for you this
week.
Radio host and columnist Ben Shapiro.
Ben Is what I would consider an old
school conservative,
which like me as a classical liberal is
a strange place to be these days.
Does he fit in with the new trump led
republican party any more than I fit in
with the identity politics driven
Democratic Party?
Not so sure.
We're both on the outside looking in and
that's exactly where I think we can
start building bridges.
I was on the daily wire livestream with
Ben on election night and I got to see
us.
He was alternately thrilled that Hillary
lost but also totally dismayed that
trump had won a couple of hours in a few
beers later.
We both managed to survive the evening
even if we didn't see eye to eye on the
whole thing.
There is huge opportunity for all of us
to shape the future of the country right
now,
but there's no way it can change if we
just complain about the system instead
of getting involved.
The rhetoric on Russia,
fake news,
stories about fake news and outrage
after outrage are not only going to keep
coming but they're going to get stronger
and stronger.
The only way we'll stop them and cut
through the noise is to figure out what
we believe and to fight for it.
I've got a new studio and a new
commitment to continue that fight and I
hope that you'll join me.
All right,
we're back,
baby.
Joining me this week is a radio host,
columnist,
editor and chief of daily wire.com
and most importantly now to Time Ruben
Report Guest Ben Shapiro.
Welcome back.
It is here.
I thought you would be the right guy to
have for the first show in our new
studio.
I don't know what you're thinking,
but sure.
Well,
because a lot has happened since we last
spoke.
Probably A,
I'd say roughly about a year ago and I
was with you on election night.
You had me over at the daily wire
studios and we had a great time and we
had some beers.
You were reading a lot of m and M's.
Oh yeah,
and that sugar intake.
Now,
the thing that I found most interesting
was that you did not like Hillary,
right?
Fair to say.
Did say,
and I think she's awful.
Not Like Hillary Clinton clearly do not
like Donald Trump.
Right.
So,
so far I'm good.
Yeah,
you're,
you're right on the money.
That's so watching you throughout that
evening,
the rollercoaster of emotions that you
were going through,
going from when I sat down,
when it's still a good for hillary to
then it's starting to look like trump
then realizing it was inevitable,
but before they called it and everything
else.
I mean you went through every emotion
alone.
Bizarro world.
Yeah,
it was definitely,
it's definitely weird because you know,
I was,
as you know,
I was sort of rooting for both of them
to get left adrift in a rowboat
somewhere.
But unfortunately one of them was going
to be presidents of the United States.
So there was,
there was a bit,
there's a lot of up and down and going
on,
meaning that I was overjoyed that
Hillary was not president of the United
States.
Anything that kept hillary out of the
White House.
I was very happy about.
And then I looked at who was actually
entering the White House and I went,
oh this,
I have some,
some trepidation about not,
not sold on the,
on this whole trump thing cause I hadn't
been,
I didn't end up voting for either of
them.
I left the blue at the top of the ticket
blank.
Neither of them fulfilled my basic
requirements to be president of the
United States.
So now you know,
I was wrong about where I thought trump
would be.
I thought trump was going to lose just
like everybody else who is looking at
the polls from nate silver to Larry
Sabato and uh,
and I was clearly a 100% wrong on that.
So now I just hope that I'm wrong about
him as a person and a president because
if I'm right,
then it's going to be a long four years.
I have a feeling that no matter what
happens,
it's going to be a little no.
I for sure.
Whether he does good stuff and people
come along for the ride or whether he
does bad stuff and they don't get as
good stuff,
then I can feel good about it.
Right?
Like I'm hoping that he does some good
stuff.
Yeah.
At this point you have to do.
Right.
Even if even if you like any of his
positions,
he's taken over the moral center that
seems to do root for him as the
president.
So I root for him to do good things.
I don't like the phrase people use this
with Obama also root for him.
I don't read for trump,
I don't refer Obama.
I didn't root for Hillary.
It's not a team sport there and I like
the white sox and the bears and the
Celtics.
I root for them.
I would like to see them win.
But in politics it's not just about
winning,
it's about what you do to win.
It's about the policies that you
implement that constitute winning.
Like how do you actually gauge winning?
So for me,
when,
when trump makes a bad deal,
that's good for him politically.
That sounds something I'm in favor of.
Right?
I'm not rooting for him,
even though it helps him politically and
I'm rooting for him to do good things.
So I'm rooting for me.
Right?
I'm,
or even from the country,
I'm rooting for him to do the things
that will help the country more than
makes I'm fine,
but help that'll help the country.
Uh,
but what I fear is that I think people
are rooting for him or rooting against
him.
And if that's your,
I sent this on my podcast today.
If,
if your moral center is basically good
for trump,
is good for the country or bad for trump
is good for the country,
you need a different moral center.
So that seems to be the place that we're
at right now.
We're trump said I'm going to win.
I'm a winner.
And that that force of will was almost
enough in and of itself,
an amazing bank,
Hema winter.
So he's your version of winning,
which would be,
uh,
you know,
having certain,
uh,
ethical code,
whatever,
whether we agree on all,
every little policy is irrelevant.
But can you win on that anymore?
Now that we've seen how trump won.
Do you honestly think that a
conservative can when you playing the
game that's out there?
I do think that,
I think that some of the things that
trump did,
and I said this very early on,
I mean very early before he started kind
of making an ass of himself repeatedly.
I said that actually there was a good
shot that he would be a better nominee
in terms of winning than Marco Rubio
because I thought that he spoke a moral
language about politics.
A lot of the other candidates didn't
mean he can go look back at my speech,
I gave it University of Missouri in like
October,
2015 and I said the trump might be
stronger,
especially among blue collar whites in
states like Wisconsin,
Pennsylvania and Michigan.
So I got it right then.
I got it wrong and your later right.
Um,
but,
but the,
but the idea there is that trump speaks
in terms of mortality.
He,
there are good guys and bad guys,
whether you agree with his mortalities
and other things,
but for politics,
for him,
all politics breaks down into good guys
versus bad guys.
Unfortunately,
very often it's just I'm the good guy.
Everybody who opposes me is the bad guy.
But that's a way that people think about
politics.
And I think that if you had the actual
proper moral,
you know,
content to that sort of narrative,
then yeah,
you could still win based on that.
It's so funny that everybody sort of,
because everybody's a binary thinker.
Uh,
everybody broke it down into a,
trump is the only one who can campaign
aggressively.
He's the only one who can speak this
moral language.
Now,
I wasn't against trump campaigning
aggressively or speaking this moral
language.
I just thought that he was applying it
incorrectly.
I mean,
if you watch me into Bain,
I'm constantly applying moral language.
I'm constantly aggressive,
but I disagreed with trump.
You can,
you can do both at the same time.
So are we at a point then of post truth?
Because if you look at what he says now,
again,
most of the criticism I get right now is
that I'm being too kind to him.
Yeah.
I've been saying for weeks now we have
to see what happens.
I can't get outraged about appointments
yet.
I have to wait to see,
you know,
you can get a sense of what's going on.
Know.
That's right.
I'm not allowed to see what happens,
but I think that's right.
I'm not,
I'm not outraged about the appointments.
Um,
you know what he does and what he says.
I can be outraged by it.
And I think that there's an incentive
structure that has to exist or if he
does something bad now,
now I criticized him.
The argument was made during the
election cycle for people on the right.
Well,
if he says something bad,
Shh,
be quiet.
Hillary might get elected.
Right.
And my view was,
that's not my job.
My job is to,
is as somebody who actually believes in
something that's truthful.
My job is to say what I think is true,
whether he's saying it or not,
but now,
especially post election,
Hillary is no longer in the picture.
So the question now is if he does
something that's false,
are you going to call that out?
Even if you're a politically on his side
overall.
And that's,
that's the real question for me.
So my job,
I still is the same as it ever was.
When he does something good,
I praise him when he does something bad,
I don't,
which really is not what many people,
people don't want that.
Now people,
people,
I mean,
it's fine.
Do they not want it?
Because I suspect they wanted,
it's what I'm trying to do.
I know it hasn't,
it hasn't hurt me,
you know,
with,
I think with most people,
most people are refreshed when they hear
somebody like you or like me say,
okay,
here's the truth.
You know,
and I'm putting my own political
interests aside and the interest of the
person who's at risk here.
Uh,
then here's,
here's what's true and here's what's
not.
But there's a large contingent that's
going to resist that in a major way
because it,
again,
it has become such a team sport.
It has become,
well,
if you say something bad about trump,
then you're a cock and you're in,
you're undermining him.
And it's like,
well,
again,
that's a,
Bill O'reilly said there about George
will,
George will criticize the carrier deal,
and Riley comes out and he says,
George,
will's just undermining.
Trump said,
wait a second.
He's not my dictator.
He's my server.
It's not right.
It's not the opposite.
I'm not his servant.
He's my servant.
He's a public servant.
Now I know that he's been in private
business his whole life,
but he was running for the job of public
servant.
Now it's his job to serve the interest
of the American people.
It's not my job to serve as his
political interests.
Yeah.
And so,
you know,
it's,
it's been very weird to watch people
kind of invert that.
Uh,
and I thought that that was unique to
the left.
So I've,
I've been disabused of that pretty
radically.
Yeah.
So that,
that's really interesting.
And maybe,
maybe my,
uh,
feelings about what's happening with the
left just kicked in a little bit more a
little earlier than yours have kicked in
about the right thing.
And that's true because you are seeing
this and it's pretty obvious.
I mean to me the issue will be that once
these trump people who have been
offered,
you know,
against political correctness and free
speech and all of this stuff and say
what you're feeling about about which
I'm for all of them,
but once on January 20th,
once,
those are the guys that are in power,
will they be as uh,
for fighting the power?
No.
Somehow suspect.
No,
no.
I mean Kellyanne Conway today,
right?
I mean Kellyanne Conway was out there
criticizing a,
I think it was a bret Stevens from the
Wall Street Journal.
Bret Stevens from the Wall Street
Journal was making fun of Carly Fiorina
cause she went to trump tower and he
says like five minutes ago you were
saying it was the worst person who ever
was and he was making fun your face.
And now here you are at trump tower and
Kellyanne conway tweets back at Bret
Stephens and she said something like,
that's really sexist.
What do you think?
And then she tags Rupert Murdoch,
right?
Who owns the Wall Street Journal,
And so is this the way that this is
going to go now that we're going to go
to the bosses of the people who we don't
like what they're saying,
right.
That's someone literally in the incoming
administration tagging someone.
Yeah.
Let me,
Sean Hannity did the same thing today.
Somebody red state criticized him,
didn't like something that he did.
So he immediately tagged the heads of
sales.
The communications.
It's tones,
red state.
I mean like is this something that we
want to engage in?
I,
this is,
this is not like I disagree with people
all the time.
I generally don't call for them to be
fired.
Right?
I mean that's it.
That's it.
Sometimes like there was a point where I
suggested that there there should be,
if someone,
if they've left us,
we're going to apply certain tactics.
Then you have to apply those same
tactics to people on the left in order
to create a sort of mutually assured
destruction.
But that's not what's going on now.
Now what's going on?
As you criticized certain people and
those people just say,
you ought to be fired just for the
criticism.
In fact,
I've never blocked anyone on twitter.
I don't mute anybody on twitter.
So all of the,
all the evil terrible tweets that I
received,
I've never called for anybody to be
banned from twitter,
even though you know,
I was,
according to the Adl,
the number one recipient of antisemitism
or one line this year.
So I mean it did,
but I've never,
but that's not my thing.
But watching people on my own side do it
now,
it's like,
well,
you should shut up because,
because trump,
no,
sorry.
That's not the way it works.
Yeah.
Can you win that battle?
I mean,
yeah,
I think you're right.
Exactly.
I mean,
as you know,
you wouldn't be in this business.
I wouldn't be in this business if I
didn't think the battle we're winnable.
I think that in the afterglow of a,
of an election,
it's very for people to get past the
team sport of it and the,
the warm feeling and the excitement.
So I immediately,
I mean,
as you mentioned that night,
I kept going from excitement and
trepidation and excitement and
trepidation to,
oh my God,
I can't believe this was the election.
And,
but a lot of people just went straight
to,
we hate Hillary Clinton so much.
Everything is now hunky Dory.
No problems anymore.
Trump's here,
I alone can solve.
And I think that'll last up until the
point where the pedal hits the metal and
then we'll see.
Yeah.
What kind of policies he actually
implements and whether people are
willing to stand up my bed is that a lot
fewer people will be willing to stand
up,
uh,
and,
and not back in when he does bad things
then,
then you would have thought a year ago.
Yeah,
I guess we shall see.
Um,
what,
what's next?
What?
Okay.
So he becomes president,
he starts doing whatever he's doing the
left automatically,
and this has been my funeral along is if
you demonize someone to the point where
even if they do good,
you have to keep demonizing them because
if he's a racist bigot,
even if even if it reads to speak,
it does good things for the economy.
Well you can't be nice to him,
right?
Because he's,
he's the scum of the earth.
What happens after this?
Because it seems to me that I think
we're going to start seeing more of a
trend of violence and you know,
the state coming down on more violence,
like it just seems like this is where
this has all been led up to and he's the
guy to to lead the fight against.
Well,
I mean,
the level of radicalism that's emerged
on both sides in terms of the,
the wild and tolerance for people with
different political opinions is pretty
extreme as you're saying.
Ah,
you know,
I think that if Democrats were smart,
they would actually see this as kind of
an opportunity.
Do that.
My guess is that trump's gonna govern as
as more of a centrist Democrat.
Then he has is a hardcore right wing
Republican.
I mean he's talking about trillion
dollar infrastructure packages and he's
talking about tariffs and he's talking
about a lot of Bernie sanders kind of
policies.
He's a populist,
right?
That's right.
And so you could win.
So what you could see Democrats is doing
is doing exactly what they did to
Herbert Hoover.
If it,
let's say if things go bad,
right?
Let's see if things go well,
he'll be reelected because of president
who's president.
When things are going well,
generally is reelected.
But let's say things.
Let's say for the sake of argument,
things don't go well.
Let's say that just as as every eight to
10 years for the last several decades in
this country,
there's some sort of recession and
Democrats blame trump for it.
What they could do is they could
campaign on triple tripling down on the
populism,
right?
I mean they actually have that opening
now,
whereas they didn't before and they
could actually do Fdr to hoover.
They could say,
you know,
hoover kind of implemented a lot of soft
fdr policies and then fdr came in and
tripled down on everything and get
selected four straight times.
You could see Democrats doing this
things shift really quickly in the
country.
And Hillary did win by about 3 million
popular votes.
So this isn't quite the,
the massive majority that Republicans
are banking on.
Um,
but I do think that if their,
if their rhetoric is this extreme,
you know,
during the campaign the question is
going to be whether they ratcheted up or
whether they sort of ratcheted down and
wait to see what happens.
I'm seeing some of both.
I'm seeing some about that.
And so yeah,
because I hope you're right.
Like Harry Reid for example,
came out and he says,
so far trump's not not that bad,
which is something that should make
conservatives a little concerned.
But Harry Reid says that you could see
Democrats move in that direction.
He's not that.
And then things collapse.
Oh,
told you he was that bad.
Right.
But the other,
cause they want to get some liberal
policy items from a lefty policy out of
it.
But on the other hand,
what's going on in university campuses
and the,
and the sort of extreme response,
uh,
that I think is going to get a lot
worse.
I think Democrats in government will
likely treat him with more moderation
after the election than they did before
the election.
Because that's sort of been the pattern.
But the typical public is going to treat
this is like we're,
we're now in an end of times
politicking.
Right?
So I guess that,
so that's an interesting distinction
that the sort of leadership,
whether it's the media or the political
leadership,
may be willing to work with them in a
certain way.
What they've ginned up something yes.
In the populous that they may be can't
control.
Exactly.
And actually you're seeing that battle
play out in the Democratic Party right
now.
You've got the people who want to double
down and all the kind of identity
politics,
rhetoric like Keith Ellison,
right?
He's going to double down on that and
he's going to keep saying racist,
sexist,
bigot.
Homophobe let's get our coalition
Together.
The Obama coalition will run somebody
who's not an old white lady.
Next time we'll run cory booker,
Kamala Harris,
and then we'll just sweep back to
victory using this new coalition that's
demographically growing.
And then you've got people like Joe
Biden and some of the old guard
Democrats who are saying,
well,
hold on just a second.
Like we can actually,
why are we abandoning all of these,
these blue collar white voters who are
voting for us until very recently,
right?
A lot of these counties went for Obama
the first time.
And why don't we,
why don't we try to draw them in by
maybe working with trump and then if he,
and then,
and then hitting him when we think that
he's over overly selling something or
hitting him when things go bad and so
that,
that conflict will really play out at
the DNC level.
Uh,
and that's,
that's a fascinating,
yeah.
I mean,
I would bet everything that they're
going to go the Bernie Ellis and rooms
dump everybody else.
Do you think there's any room for those
people that you know for a gym where
Biden,
those happened to be two older white
guys,
but he's been anyone in that general
line of thinking blue dog Democrat is
that right
now Jim Webb,
right.
I think Jim Webb's toast biden still
tries to straddle that gap a little bit
and he gets away with it cause he's part
of the Obama administration.
Yeah,
but it's,
yeah,
I think they're going to be gradually
drag to the left cause again in our
entire life the left has been gradually
drag further and further to the left and
I'm waiting to see the moderates since
Clinton.
They've been,
yeah,
that's the thing.
I think for a long time that the right
got dragged further in front of the
right.
But this election,
clearly they weren't.
No,
they weren't.
They were dragged the left actually
pretty hard.
They weren't,
I mean trump doesn't,
it's obvious he doesn't care about gay
marriage,
I don't think.
No,
I don't think he cares about abortion,
cares about weed.
I think even some of the tax stuff I
think is going to be a little more,
you write the ending,
at least centrist Democrat,
I think he's going to govern a lot more
like Bill Clinton.
Then he,
then he would govern like Ronald Reagan.
That's the danger though.
If you demonize somebody to that end
point and then even if they are with you
on so many of the things that you've
been screaming about for so long,
you're,
you've painted yourself into that.
Yeah,
I think,
I think that's right and I think the
Democrats have painted themselves in a
little bit of a corner except that
they're just banking on the growth of
the Obama coalition.
They keep looking at the demographic
numbers.
Yeah,
and they keep thinking,
okay,
in 2020 40% of all voters will be of the
millennial generation.
Those people broke heavily for hilary,
so what's to stop us now and
demographics are not quite destinee.
I mean demographic.
What a sad way
that would be to live as a society that
we would only be following the
demographic trend,
but that's what we are right now.
We've moved in such a tribal direction
too.
I mean it's easy to look at this
election cycle and look at did he went
on policy?
I don't think that the trump one on
policy so much as rejection of tribalism
in favor of another sort of tribalism.
Like if you look at how blue collar
white voters voted in this election
cycle by percentage white,
we're a white working class.
People voted more for trump than
Hispanics voted for Hillary Clinton and
people are constantly talking about the,
the idea that Hispanics are voting
block.
Okay,
well then so are white blue collar
people presumably and they voted
precisely the reverse.
They will be 71% for trump.
That's it.
Again,
I don't have a problem with people with
any group voting,
however they want to vote,
but if,
if it starts to look like a voting
block,
like our group interest,
solidarity,
I don't think that's,
that's totally what's happening,
I don't think is a bunch of white people
getting together and going,
oh,
we've got to vote against this black and
Hispanic people.
Right.
Just like,
I don't think that it's all Hispanic
people getting together.
We need to vote against the white
people,
but it,
but there is that,
that growing sense that you're going to
vote inside your own block and it,
and that is not a good thing.
Do you think that's actually real
though?
Because every time I watched John King
with the Magic Wall that I'm pretty sure
he's having an affair with commercial
breaks,
but every time I watch them do that and
said,
well,
the white working class people here in
the black people here in the Latino
people here in this whole thing.
And it's like,
not only does that actually sort of
sound racist and I don't know,
it doesn't mean it's actually just
pinning everyone by these,
these traits.
Uh,
but it also doesn't sound logical.
I don't think,
and maybe I'm really wrong here,
but I don't think most people vote on
the color of their skin or no,
I don't think so either.
But I think that they vote like their
neighbors vote.
And so and so if they see that their
neighbors are voting a certain way and
there's a certain revenge politics to
everything,
and this is not unique to one group,
it's like the system has screwed us.
This is the system has screwed us is one
of the ways that politics dies,
that that notion,
the system has screwed us.
And I don't just mean like the
government,
if you can show that the government is
specifically disadvantage in your group,
that's one thing.
But when you just say the system broadly
is screwing us and it's to us as white,
blue collar workers,
or it's us as black people or it's us as
Hispanics,
that's a really damaging thing.
And,
and that I think is,
is rising pretty dramatically.
And,
and that's partially because the only
way that politics operates,
and I've spoken about this at length
recently,
uh,
but the,
the only way that politics actually
operates and the way society operates is
through building of the social fabric.
The idea that we are individuals who are
going to treat each other as
individuals.
We're not going to treat each other as
members of groups will have to spend so
long breaking people down into identity
group politics that the Wright responded
with it's own form of,
okay,
well screw you,
we're,
you know,
you've already boxed us in.
So okay,
now that we're in the box,
we're in the box.
Like that's what it is.
Right?
It's almost like they're,
they hated it for so long,
but now they're embracing it.
You sleep.
Right.
I've tried so hard to have the left back
away from some of this stuff.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
And I'd like to see the right back away
from some of this stuff.
I think that's what a lot of the
outright controversy was about because
they're really open about the tribalism.
But I mean,
there's no question that,
that some of what trump was doing was,
it was a quasi tribal appeal.
Right?
I mean when,
when he was talking about tariffs,
for example,
the terrorists that he's talking about,
you know,
he,
he's saying that he obviously they're,
they're equally applicable to people
living in the United States,
but really who he's talking to,
and everybody knew this and it was
repeated ad nauseum in the media was
he's talking to white,
blue collar voters from Ohio,
Pennsylvania,
Michigan and Wisconsin.
And when you say to people that you can
indirectly tax other people for your
benefit,
which is what a tariff is,
but it's okay for the white people,
but we also don't like the welfare
system for the black people,
then you start getting into some really,
you know,
kind of interesting political territory
and the idea that it was a totally race
free campaign by trump is not true.
I mean,
it just,
it wasn't like the,
the fact is that Donald Trump was making
a,
not overt references to race,
but he was making subtle appeals on the
basis of race free campaign or there
people,
I think there are people,
yeah,
I mean Kellyanne Conway to go to
example,
right?
She says,
she said there was a big debate between
her and Jen Palmieri from the Clinton
campaign and Jen Palmieri,
he said that you guys were pandering to
the outright and Kellyanne Conway said,
you're,
you're accusing me of being part of a
campaign that would pander to the alt
right.
And Jen Palmieri.
He said,
yeah,
and,
but Kelly entered the who?
Me,
me,
what?
And it's like,
oh yeah,
you a little bit.
And yet at the same time,
the Democrats were pandering to
everybody keeps saying,
we don't exactly,
don't talk about race,
but every other line was raised.
Exactly.
And so it's,
and so you have both sides playing the
same game now,
and none of them are playing inside the
mentality that we're where I exist.
Which,
you know,
you put it outside the conservative box
for a second.
I am essentially a radical individualist
in the sense that I think that people
ought to be treated as individuals.
They shouldn't be treated as part of
groups.
And so treating voters as part of a
group or a classical liberal.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
And did have that.
Sure.
Unlike the European style classical
limmer.
Yeah,
I mean except the,
yeah,
I mean with,
with some really like the conservative
thing enough that even to say that I
know,
I mean I'm more,
I'm more kind of a conservative
libertarian mashup than anything else.
I think the government sucks at
everything,
right?
I mean like we've talked about same sex
marriage before.
I personally against same sex marriage,
but I don't think the government has any
business in it.
And personally,
again,
smoking marijuana,
I don't think the government has pretty
much any business in it.
If you're not creating extra analogies,
I don't think that the government has
any business messing with you.
So that's why I can sit across from you
and you can say that and it doesn't
bother me because at this point you're
not trying to stop either one of those
things.
Right.
Exactly.
Why?
So you can believe what you want to
believe.
They said that this is,
I know I'm supposed to be offended.
Right,
exactly.
But this is,
this is the thing that is so funny.
I was talking to somebody one time and
they were saying,
you know,
as a,
as a religious person,
you think homosexual behavior is a sin
as a right,
as an Orthodox Jew,
right?
It's in the Bible.
I think it's a sin.
Here's the beautiful thing about
America.
You don't have to give a crap.
You don't,
you can think I'm an idiot.
That's fine.
Right.
Welcome to America and,
and yeah,
you don't use seriously can completely
disregard everything I'm saying because
I'm not trying to use a gun to enforce
my opinion against you.
And actually you're not even trying to
use the Bible because,
right,
exactly.
We're not trying to govern by the Bible.
That's,
that's you're saying.
That's right.
You're saying you have your private
belief.
Right.
Exactly.
We lose this ability to have the private
league because did you see this about a
week ago?
Uh,
buzzfeed did a piece on the two people
from that
Hg TV show.
Blanking on the show.
I watch it sometimes.
You want to be one of the gains couple.
Yeah,
the gaines,
Joanna,
and what I can remember,
I don't want your child,
but yeah,
they,
you know,
they do this house flipping show.
It might be great flip or flop or,
or whatever it's called.
Uh,
but the point is that what it is,
so I've watched the show many times,
they strike me as two completely benign,
whatever.
Find people like their jobs seem like
these people.
And the whole piece in buzzfeed wasn't
that they go to a church that's against
gay marriage.
And I thought this is the worst kind of
smear job nonsense.
Exactly.
And,
but when did that become,
okay,
so what?
They go to a church where we don't know
what their beliefs are on it and I
wouldn't care actually.
Right,
exactly.
And even if they believe that as long as
they're not manifesting that in
discrimination against gay people,
who gives a crap,
right?
I mean,
this is,
this is ridiculous.
I mean,
first of all,
the idea that HDTV is short on pandering
to gay people isn't,
it?
Is Patently insane.
Okay.
My wife watches HGTV.
We learned all about,
but let's,
let's,
uh,
but it,
it is amazing.
I mean that sort of thought policing.
Uh,
I mean that's existed for a couple of
decades,
probably since the 60s for the left.
But the fact that it's starting to exist
a little bit on the right is what
frightens me is,
is the,
the thought policing,
uh,
that I see because policies become a
loyalty test,
but it's also
so selective in what everyone does.
Because I would guarantee you mentioned
Keith Ellison a moment ago.
I'm going to guess that the mosque that
he goes to is probably the mom is
probably not for gay marriage,
but buzzfeed I do.
I'm just guessing on that.
But I'm pretty sure that that's majority
mosques are not yet probably 99.9%
of mosques in America or not.
Okay.
That's fine.
They can have their personal religious
belief,
but buzzfeed would never do a piece on
that.
If anything,
they'll whitewash everything he's ever
said about fire can and everything else.
Right,
exactly.
So that just shows you how the media
has,
and I
again,
they did,
they said that they were fine with,
with Obama's excuse.
Then you went to a church for 20 years
where Jeremiah Wright was preaching the
most insane crap imaginable from the
pulpit.
And they just went,
okay,
well,
you know,
that's his church and nobody says he has
to believe that.
And I said,
wait,
wait a second,
why does that,
that's okay for Obama,
but it's not to confirm gains.
Yeah.
Obama is like the,
he's going to actually run for
president.
Like if at any point the guy's views are
going to be relevant,
you would think it's more of that then,
I don't know,
are you gonna knock out a,
a barrier and create an open kitchen
concept on HIV baby?
Right,
right.
It's a,
yeah,
it is.
It is.
It is pretty,
it's pretty wild how far things have
gone.
Um,
and I'm hoping that,
I think that a lot of people who are
hoping that trump is going to be a blow
back against that,
that,
that there'll be less thought policing,
uh,
under trump.
But that also has to apply to trump,
right?
Right.
Then has to apply to trump himself and
it has to apply to the chief.
When Kellyanne Conway's tagging people,
the bosses on twitter that they don't
like,
that doesn't,
that's not a good thing.
Let me,
Donald Trump was making those noises all
throughout the campaign.
Right.
He said he wants to rewrite libel law,
which for people in our business is
like,
I mean,
all we do all day is sit and give
opinions on people.
And the idea that we're going to be sued
for giving those opinions,
uh,
is,
is pretty frightening thing in the
United States.
Yeah.
But it isn't so much of that though,
and I think you've already said this,
but that it's just a reaction to the
lunacy.
Yeah.
Trump's reaction and the reaction to him
is reactionary.
There's no question,
but reactionary politics is bad
politics.
Right.
You should have the,
the reaction to the left has been
breaking people down by,
by race and by identity.
Politics is not,
well,
screw them.
Let's do identity politics too.
If they can do what we can do it,
you know,
that's not the,
that's not the way they got to play the
game.
I mean,
it's,
and if you think that's the only way we
can win,
then we're bound for a European style
politics.
It's the end of American politics.
Like what America used to be about was
the idea that as individuals,
we disagreed about a lot of things,
but we agreed that we were going to be
treated as individuals,
or at least that was the,
that was supposed to be the promise that
we were attempting to fulfill.
Uh,
in Europe,
it all breaks down according to
demographic lines and you just have a
battle between the big government right
in the big government left and are you
going to let in immigrants this time or
you're not going to get let in
immigrants this time?
That's,
that's,
yeah.
And I think that we're in danger of
moving that way.
Just we're going to,
we're going to show it and freight our
way right into something really ugly.
Yeah.
In a weird way though,
this presents a tremendous amount of
opportunity,
right?
I was telling you right before we
started,
I was with you a couple of weeks ago,
a Dennis prager had a,
had a fundraiser and I thought he gave a
really great speech about basically
saying the world is in a really nuts
place right now and maybe we have to
find allies and other places.
And that's what I think I've tried to
do.
So there is for all the chaos of it.
Yeah,
there's some real life.
I mean,
I hope so.
And I hope that it's,
I think it's a good opportunity for a,
and when I do my podcast,
I actually keep a physical shoe on the
side and I,
and I hold it up and I say,
put this on the other foot.
Right?
Whenever it trump does something.
So you just put this on there that with
Obama did this,
how would you feel?
And it's a good opportunity for people
on the left to do the same thing.
I think that if we all sort of take the
shoe and put it on the other foot,
like now you're very upset with what
trump's doing,
but how are you with it?
When,
when Obama was doing it,
if you think is bad,
when trump's doing,
and maybe it was bad when Obama was
doing it and for the right,
if you were really pissed off about it
when Obama was doing it and now trump's
doing it,
maybe you should be pissed off when
trump's doing it.
Ah,
and if everybody applied,
that sort of intellectual honesty I
think to,
to whatever our politicians do,
we'd be significantly better off.
Because the fact is that it's the team
sport of it,
the ruins it,
it's a team sport of it that where you
end up with,
I'm going to root for,
for my guy,
just no matter what he does,
no matter what rules he breaks.
And this is why I've said it's not seems
more politics is not team sport.
Like as a white sox fan,
there was a catcher who caught for us
named Aga presents gate at aeg presents.
He was a player that everybody hated and
still hates in the major thing plays to
the braves.
Now they despise him cause he was this
guy who had like cut any corner to win.
And when he's not on your team,
you hate him.
And then he's on your team and you'll
love him.
Right?
Yes.
Anything in order to win.
The problem is that when you apply that
to politics and it's,
if he's on my team and he'll do anything
to win,
that's awesome.
Yeah.
Well except for it isn't because now you
have to,
you have to be standing up for people
doing bad things.
Yeah.
And that's the strange thing.
I mean,
look,
if you were for all these people that
are upset that Oh,
trump might be a warmonger or might be
against the press neck,
he might be,
but at this,
but hey,
he didn't run certainly on on a pro war
policy will be,
Obama has been doing drone strikes into
Afghanistan,
strikes in Pakistan,
ask Edward Snowden how he's been for
press freedom and all that kind of
stuff.
So regardless of what,
how were you feeling?
Terrible for press brakes.
It's like,
wait,
nobody,
why weren't you guys saying anything
that you'd have a little more right.
Yeah.
You'd have a little more weight to your
words now.
Exactly.
I said this on Brian stelter show on CNN
is they were going over,
this is when,
when trump was tweeting against
Hamilton,
and I said,
like,
let's,
let's be fair to both sides.
If Obama had done this to a nascar
event,
like some Nascar event in 2011 boot,
Michelle,
and he'd gone on and said,
these Nascar people should shut up and
apologize.
Basically,
you know,
it would've been applauded,
but he would have been applauded by the
left.
And now trump does on Hamilton and it's
just the end of the world.
Oh my God,
he's going to shut down our beloved
Hamilton.
And he's,
by the way is right.
It's an overrated musical.
But the,
but,
but on the other side,
I haven't seen it on the other side.
Uh,
you know,
he had people on the right and they're
like,
yeah,
look at trump.
Really punching,
really,
really taking it to them.
I was like,
all right,
but when Obama did exactly the same sort
of stuff,
when he was calling out Fox News by name
and saying that it was that they were
destroying the political process,
we were saying,
wait,
the the president of the United States
should be going out and attacking
specific news outlets for how they
report.
That's really gross.
It's so funny.
I had somebody tweet me saying,
why didn't you ever say this stuff about
Obama?
And I linked directly to a video from
2013 I said exactly this about Obama and
it's in again,
you could probably spend your whole life
trying to correct the things that people
tweet.
But that's what happens is that people
get into this,
the,
they get into this mode where,
yeah,
when Obama did it,
it was the Democrats didn't care.
And it's like,
yeah,
but that,
that argument also applies to you.
You did care when Obama did it and now
you're pretending not to.
So the hypocrisy argument cuts both
ways.
It's double edged sword.
He can't claim the Democrats are
hypocrites about trump at the same time
that you're being a hypocrite about
Obama.
All right,
so let's shift away from a little bit of
the horse race pilot from broader
themes.
So the free speech stuff,
you have been in the thick of it.
I mean,
yeah,
it's going to party truly,
truly in the thick of this,
you get protested at pretty much every,
when's the last time you were at a
university that you weren't protests?
And I mean,
I would say half the universities.
I go try,
I protest protested.
I mean I go to a lot of universities.
I,
I've,
I've spoken at 10 in the last two months
I would say.
I guess I only hear about the one,
we only see the headlines about the ones
where there are heavy protests had taken
maybe a third of them.
I get heavy protests.
Okay.
So about a third of them,
you're getting heavy protests now.
I would venture to say that for everyone
that's listening to this interview so
far,
whether they agree with you or not,
you don't seem to be a hate monger or
some sort of white supremacist or Jewish
supremacist or some other Nazi related
something or other like,
okay,
what are these people thinking?
What do you really think is going on for
these people?
Cause it's a lot of misguided nonsense.
And,
and I've spoke at Ucla with Milo,
which is a whole separate crowd.
Your crowd obviously.
Uh,
but there are protesting him too.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean I think that the,
for the most part people,
I don't assume my own level of
notoriety.
So I think that most of the people who
are protesting me,
I've never heard anything that I've said
or read anything that I've written.
Yeah,
exactly.
When I was at Wisconsin,
one of the things that a lot of the
fliers come out and the fliers put like
the most provocative title they can to
get people to come.
Right.
Um,
and then usually that they're,
they're fine.
But it did.
But,
uh,
for example,
Wisconsin,
I had people getting up and chanting.
I had a guy right at the beginning stand
up and say something about how I was
enabling Hitler.
And I was like,
dude,
do you see the Yamaka?
Like what are,
what are you even talking about?
Like what are you talking about?
And then they were chanting,
they were chanting f white supremacy.
It,
man,
it's like I've been spending this entire
election cycle under assault from the
white supremacists,
right?
Because I told them that they,
that they're wrong.
And I think that they're evil and the,
and literally the number one online
target of the,
all right,
so how about right?
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
And so,
but I'm getting protested by it,
by the,
by the blm crowd.
And so it's,
I think that it comes from ignorance.
I think it comes from this place where
any opposing view must be attacked and
we don't even have to do our research.
We don't have to try and debunk it.
It's a bunking.
It actually takes effort going and
yelling about it doesn't take any effort
at all.
And that's why whenever I do these
lectures,
the first thing I do when we do q and,
a,
as I say,
if you disagree with me,
you get to go first.
All people who disagree go to the front
of the line and it's and it,
cause that's always more interesting and
I treat the people who disagree with me
actually with respect.
If you're not,
if you're not yelling at me and you're
not flipping me off and shutting f white
supremacy,
I'm happy to treat you with respect and
have a civil discussion.
I do it all the time and that's the one
you can win over.
Right,
exactly.
It's selfishly rewarding for you because
that's the guy who was on the fence that
might come to your thigh or at the very
least we can have a discussion where the
person gives a point.
I get the counterpoint and all the,
all the whole audience is smarter for
it,
that the audience is not smarter for
having these people chance and stand in
front of the stage and try to disrupt an
event and me write more ons on the trop
board behind them.
I mean,
it's fun for me and I think it's fun for
the crowd,
but it's not,
but it's not informative in any way
except to show that there are these
people who are out there.
How does it feel just just on the
personal level when this stuff's
happening?
Cause there are threats.
I mean,
again,
when I was at Ucla,
I think there was a bomb threat.
People bashing on the door,
seemed like they were coming in
screaming like we didn't know if by,
you know,
uh,
anything violent could happen.
Like all that stuff.
Like just on a purely personal note,
you are a person,
you're a relatively new father I think.
Like,
yeah,
I've got two kids in three years.
Yeah.
Okay.
So just on that note,
like putting yourself out there like
that,
what do you make of that?
Uh,
well,
I mean,
I don't tell my wife about it.
She,
she not on twitter,
on twitter.
She does not do the facebook thing.
I off everything.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like,
Hey,
she's,
she's kind of protected from it.
Um,
I have,
I feel like I'm usually the safest
person in the room.
I'm the only guy there were security,
right?
So I've got my own private security,
uh,
that we contract to do these things.
The first time we did it,
I was like,
why are we even doing this?
And turned out that was cal state La and
there's like an actual riot there.
So it's,
so yeah,
I'm now,
I've got security guys who come with me.
Um,
I'm always relieved when it's not that
because again,
I would much prefer to have just a
normal,
like I'm not looking for the,
I really am not looking for the headline
that says protesters come in,
Shapiro finishes protesters or whatever
like that.
Honestly,
that's easy for me.
It's not hard.
Like these people have a combined icu in
single digits.
It's not difficult to make stupid people
look stupid.
It's more difficult to actually have a
conversation with somebody who has a
point of view and some facts to back
them.
I was more interesting.
Um,
but you know,
as far as the personal safety aspect of
it,
um,
I,
it doesn't,
it doesn't concern me.
It's physical safety as much as just
sort of your men mostly puzzled.
I'm like,
what?
Why?
Like what am I saying?
Like I'm here preaching decency and non
identity group politics and I'm getting
protested for that.
Like I have people yelling at me and
threatening violence because of that.
Right.
I could understand if I were coming here
and I was saying something that's,
that's you know,
actively calling for violence or
something or even implying that violence
is okay in any way.
But half of my speeches are about why
violence is never okay.
Right?
Like you don't get to hit people if you
disagree with them.
And then to prove my point that come and
they try and hit people who disagree
with them.
It's just like,
it's so bizarre.
Right.
Where were you with the,
with Christina Hoff.
Sommers Paul.
Yeah.
Paul.
Which depaul is banned by low.
Right.
And then the,
the,
well they ban Milo and then they
immediately banned me on top of that.
Right.
Like housing.
They're like,
and,
and then first of all,
this is absurd.
They Ban Milo.
Everybody knows about the disagreements
that I have with my,
but it's absurd.
Milo getting banned from campuses.
I'm sure it makes me really happy
because the headline,
but um,
but it's,
it's stupidity of the highest order.
Uh,
if you disagree with him,
go into bunk him.
Um,
if you disagree with them,
don't show up.
I mean,
that'd be the worst thing you can do to
Milo is just not show up for one of his
lectures.
Um,
but it's it.
But the,
you know,
they banned me on top of that at Depaul.
Uh,
and then they didn't even give it like
they're only excuse was the security and
it was like,
he can't control your own students.
That's not my fault.
That's your fault.
You're a university.
Should be doing that.
And then you can go view the video.
They actually,
uh,
we announced that Christina was going to
be speaking there and I was going to,
you know,
accompany her and they wouldn't let me
in the building as a guest.
They wouldn't let me in the building as
a member of her team and they wouldn't
let me in the building and just sit in
the audience.
What are they saying to you at that
time?
Are they saying because their people are
threatening violence and there were no
threats of violence?
That was what was amazing at Depaul.
Like we walked up and the whole day
they'd been telling my security team
that if Shapiro shows up that we're
going to arrest him.
If he shows up then we will literally
and at the,
at the place for trespass.
Right.
So I mean that would be the crime is
trespassing on their campus.
They literally went out and got a share
from Cook County to sit there to
facilitate the transfer of arrest.
If the campus police arrest you,
they have to have somebody from the
county actually be,
it's actually,
you have the guy sitting there in the
law?
No protesters anywhere.
None.
Right.
I mean it's 30 police officers and
security guards and me and I walk up and
I was like really?
Like I can't it like Sofa.
And I said,
you know,
if I take two steps forward,
are you going to arrest me?
And the guy said,
yeah and giant guy.
Yeah.
People were like,
you should have,
you should have gotten arrested.
It's like well you know at that point
I'm really not so hot on spending the
evening.
And They Cook County prison,
Cook County jail for the,
for the of your beliefs,
but not to the point of,
well again,
they actually have the right to arrest
me.
It's a private university.
If it were a public university,
I would have walked,
if you were in private,
if a Republican diversity,
I would have made them arrest me at a
private university.
They do have the,
they do have the legal right to,
to band whoever they want.
It just demonstrates how ridiculous they
are that they're willing to arrest me.
And the fact that again,
that they're taking everyone from you to
milo,
it's like that's showing real
intolerance.
Cause it's not just a sleep.
It's not just [inaudible].
It's people that disagree wildly on
things.
Exactly.
Well they except,
except if they are remotely construed as
right wing.
Right.
So if you're,
if you're in a,
if you're a terrorist convicted in
Israel,
you can speak at a,
they had one speaker in 2014 I think at
Depaul.
So if you,
so you have to be within a certain
spectrum,
but they refused to even acknowledge a
spectrum.
Right.
Although depaul actually did write
depaul,
depaul came out later and they,
and they tried to distinguish kind of
what I say from what Milo says,
which is kind of interesting.
But that didn't change their behavior
enough to actually let me speak.
Yeah.
All right,
so let's,
let's just do the Milo thing quick.
I don't want to,
I don't want to dwell on it,
but,
but so many people ask.
So for the record that you sitting here
right now,
I will fully say what I've said many
times on twitter,
which is that my low had the original
idea of doing it.
He sent an email to our team,
said,
let's do this debate.
Me and Ben,
table moderate,
you immediately responded,
yes,
you gave dates.
And then Milo basically dipped out that
says the truth.
As much as I know it
and say,
no,
that's exactly right.
And so,
and then went around the country
proclaiming that I had chicken down and
trying to derive this rivalry with me
that I could not care less about.
Like Milo,
I wish nothing but success to,
to my low based on the good things he
does.
I hope nothing but failure for him,
for bad things that he does just like
anybody else.
And it's,
and you know,
as in,
you know,
I'm not going to play Lucy and the
football with him and he ducked out.
He chickened out.
And uh,
and I mean,
look,
the fact is that even the fact I was
willing to do it in the first place
after he was tweeting pictures of me as
a black baby on the day that my son was
born because I'm a cock,
it was,
was a bit generous.
But then now that I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna play that game.
That's not my game.
And the thing is,
I genuinely liked both of you and I
think we could have done something
really good.
I have my own coming back in in
February.
I think that,
my guess is that the ground,
the ground is a little too scorch.
Yeah.
I'm not,
I'm not interested.
Yeah,
okay.
Again,
I'm not interested in doing the Charlie
Brown lucy routine so that he can go
around the country proclaiming that he's
brave after having checked it out.
Yeah.
And for the record,
when he comes in in February,
I'll say the exact same thing to him and
he can say,
well,
that's fine.
That's fine.
Um,
all right.
I'll be very sophisticated in British
stuff.
Uh,
the alt right thing.
Now I have done a couple of videos on
the alt right.
I general feeling,
although I think something is changing
now that trump is in power,
is that for the months leading up to the
election,
this was mostly a bunch of shit posters.
It was mostly a bunch of anonymous four
Chan and reddit people.
It was not really white supremacists and
neo Nazis.
There were some of these people in the
mix of it,
but it was just people who were home in
their basements or wherever that were
tweeting at people in power media,
people,
politicians to upset everybody,
to get them retweeted,
to get everyone to show,
I'm such a victim,
look at me,
look what's happening to me online.
I'm separate.
And basically what I've said is if we
deal with some of these issues,
honestly,
like immigration or Islam,
Islam or something,
that's how we'll defang some of the
rhetoric around all this stuff.
And so I think there's truth to that.
Now.
I think it's starting to shift a little
bit now that,
that trump won the election,
right?
No,
I think,
I think there's truth to that.
So what I've distinguished in interviews
or talking about this is the outright
philosophers and promulgators Milo's a
problem we had of the alt right.
Uh,
and he denies head,
but he likes to play the clown nose off
clown nose,
offer a teen and clown nose on clown
nose offers him with the outright.
Yes.
I'm not,
I'm not really a member of the outright.
I just write stories giving they're
expressing their viewpoints.
Uh Huh.
Um,
but it's,
uh,
but the,
the piece that he wrote for,
for Breitbart about the outright is a
really definitive piece about what the
alt right is.
Uh,
and I think that for the most part it's
pretty accurate.
Uh,
there,
the,
the outright philosophy isn't a lot of
people who consider themselves outright
right or not technically outright right?
They are,
as you say,
shit posters,
right?
There are people who have been drawn in
by the idea that they're being
politically incorrect and they're
violating taboos.
And it's kind of fun to do that.
And it's very teenagery and all this
kind of stuff.
Um,
the people who are actually hardcore old
writers,
people who,
Milo,
he knows that her philosophy and he
talked about it and that piece,
right?
The people,
the Richard Spencers and the jury,
Taylor's and all those groups,
those people out,
our actual honest to God,
white supremacists.
And there's a line in that piece where
he talks about about civil as Western
civilization being inseparable from
ethnicity,
uh,
which is white supremacy,
right?
That that is definition of white
supremacy.
So it's a,
so that's the philosophy,
but a lot of people consider themselves
outright,
had been dragged into that by people who
have been inaccurate in their
definitions of the alt right.
So instead of just saying,
okay,
there's the,
the people who actually believe this
white supremacist crap,
and then they're a bunch of people who
are just posting stupid stuff online to
get a rise out of people.
They had conflate the two.
And then what's even worse is that you
get people who are legit,
you know conservatives who don't know
what the alt right is.
And so they assume that everybody who is
antiestablishment is outright.
And so that gives them a number that
they don't actually hold.
Right.
The number of people who are definitely,
who are really outright,
like the people who actually believe in
white nationalism or white superiority,
that's a really small number of people.
It really is.
And then they've built themselves out.
They've kind of built this,
this,
there's the,
there's the core and then there's the
chaff.
They've built this kind of large chaff
sphere around themselves.
And one of the,
I think tasks we have is to try and
separate the core from the chaff and
say,
okay,
you know,
all you people who are anti
establishment,
listen,
I'm antiestablishment too.
I think Mitch Mcconnell is terrible.
I was not a fan of Paul Ryan,
but that's not the same thing as being
alt right.
And so,
you know what I'm fearful of is the
winks and nods to the actual outright.
Like I think when I say winks and nods,
and I've been saying this for awhile,
like when,
when Donald Trump was on tv and he was
asking about the KKK,
I don't Kkk,
I've never heard of them.
What are you talking?
Okay.
Like we all know that you've heard of
the KKK.
We all know you've heard of David Duke.
You're your microphone didn't
malfunction.
You were,
you'd be like you,
it was two days before the Louisiana
primary and you didn't want to alienate
voters who thought you were going to win
in the Louisiana primary.
Right?
That's,
that's what was going on there.
That was,
that was a wink and a nod,
right when Donald Trump was retweeting
white white nationalist accounts,
right.
When he's,
when he's granting legitimacy to some
kind of,
I wouldn't say fully outright figures,
but people who are very popular with the
alt right,
the Alex Jones crowd.
Uh,
that's,
that's the kind of stuff where you're
getting into kind of a gray area.
Um,
but the do I do,
I think they're an upward moe,
an upwardly mobile threat.
I think.
No,
because I think their philosophy is so
repugnant that most people,
the vast majority of people think that's
stupid.
But I think it's easy to sucker people
into thinking they're all right.
And the game there is you sucker people
into thinking they're all right and then
like me attack the outright,
then they go,
oh,
he must be attacking me.
It's like I'm not attacking you.
Yeah.
Okay.
So you post a puppy meme,
like,
okay,
so I think you're stupid,
but I don't think you're all right.
Right.
I think,
but as I said before on your show,
and I got a lot of flack for it,
if you tweet at me something that's
indistinguishable from David Duke,
it's not my responsibility to determine
your motive.
Like it's a tweet.
I'm going to treat that the same way
that I would treat treated tweet from
David Duke.
It's an idiotic tweet from an idiotic
person.
So how much
then is just related to the Internet
culture in general?
Because so when I saw the,
was it spencer in DC?
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I've had a family members on both
sides.
My Dad's side and my mom's side die in
the Holocaust.
I suspect you probably did as well.
Um,
so I don't take kindly to that in any
way.
Uh,
I don't like it.
I'd rather not see neo Nazis and all of
that stuff.
However,
I saw that and my thought was these are
200 losers.
And unfortunately we've now,
the media will now run this.
It'll be on CNN all day long.
Everyone will keep talking about it,
talking about and talking about people.
Tell me all the time,
talk about it.
Talk about it more.
Yeah.
And it's like all we're doing is
inflating this thing that these people
have always existed.
Hate is always going to exist.
I can't make every person Niagara eight
black people,
I can't make every person not a juice or
gay people or whatever it is.
It's,
it's human nature.
You may not like it,
but it's human nature.
And I think we're,
we're inflating this stuff.
Yeah.
So I,
I agree with that and I've,
and I've argued against sort of the
inflation,
but by the same token,
I think that there's been empowerment of
the fellow travelers and people who the
outright sees a sort of ideological
forebears people like Pat Buchanan and I
mentioned Alex Jones.
Alex Jones probably isn't technically
all right or wouldn't consider himself
thoughts,
but when he talks about Jewish influence
in the media,
in his rand's,
he's obviously granting them a lot of
kind of credibility and,
and he's giving them some ammunition to
feel like they have a allies.
There are a lot of people who seem to be
okay with,
with benefiting from the shit posters
and the,
and the alt right groups.
Uh,
if they can gain traffic.
That was my main critical Breitbart by
the way.
Like when I said that,
that Steve Bannon was appealing to the
alt right.
That's because he called himself the
Plat Breitbart a platform for the alt
right.
And the idea was that he was,
and this is always been my critique of
Steve and the left doesn't understand
anything remotely approaching
moderation.
So my critique of Steven Breitbart was
always that what had happened was that
Breitbart had been moved and direction
when they were willing to pander to some
of the worst people on Earth.
My posting material that appealed to
those people.
Uh,
and,
and that demonstrates to me a tremendous
will for power from,
from Steve and a willingness to work
with anyone to get there.
And that's my main critique.
And the left immediately sees done,
oh,
well he must be an antisemite.
It must be a racist.
And it's like,
no,
that's what I said.
I said,
he's an opportunist.
You've gone out of your way to say that
you don't think he's in it,
but no,
I don't.
I don't have any evidence at all.
But Steve's an antisemite.
Yeah,
no,
I think Steve's an asshole.
But I don't think she's an asset to
them.
Right.
So what do you make of that then?
So you worked with the guy who worked,
he was technically your boss,
right?
And you're like,
yeah,
and he's chairman of the company.
Yeah.
So he was technically your boss.
You have no evidence that he's an
antisemite,
right.
You as the,
as the Adl said,
you were the number attack,
a recipient of antisemetic abuse online.
So you are aware of the idea of it.
For sure.
And I will say it again,
there are people who probably will get
this following.
So for example,
when Milo was banned from twitter at my
Auntie's medic feed went down 70%
immediately.
Really?
Oh yeah.
And so,
but see the question,
to know where those his,
where those actual antisemites or shit
posters in all likelihood they're shit
posters.
Yeah.
I would guess that 90% of them are.
But what you are doing is you're
mainstreaming the idea that this sort of
rhetoric is okay.
Because in,
this was always my critique of,
of sort of the,
the notion that it's the same thing to
be politically incorrect as it is to
just be a bad person.
Right.
Like if it like political,
the,
the whole point of fighting political
correctness is so you can say true
things in order to promulgate better
ideas.
It's not,
you can then you're not doing it in the
world any good by just shouting the n
word.
Yeah.
Right.
Not doing me any good or the world any
good by just tweeting people pictures of
black kids.
Cause you're a cock.
Yeah.
What,
what,
how,
how is the world become a better place
because it has the dialogue become any
better because of that.
You certainly have the right to do it.
I'm not arguing.
You don't have the right to do it.
Yeah.
But you also have the right slap
yourself in the face of the frying pan.
You know,
that's the,
you have the right to do lots of stupid
thing.
Yeah.
The question is there are people who
aren't making the affirmative case that
this is making the country a better
place and making the dialogue more open
when in reality what you're actually
doing is you're breeding the resistance
to the dialogue.
Right,
because then,
yeah,
look,
I guess what those people would argue is
that the system has become so rigid and
so afraid of everything and every idea
that the only way you,
I mean,
I think my actually said this to me on
my show,
which was a year before the election
that this was the only way we were going
to break any of this,
but even Milo knows he's lying.
Yeah.
Next one mile is on.
Ask Him one question if he thinks that's
true,
ask him to say the n word on your show.
That's the most rigid taboo in American
society.
Asked me to say the n word.
If he really believes that all taboos
oughta be broken because taboos are
worthy of being broken,
and then we have to break down the
system.
Ask Him if he has the ball sitting on
word on your show.
I will do that.
I guarantee you,
he says no.
All right,
so I'm going to guess that we can't
solve the entire alt right thing right
here,
but I think something we can possibly
solve is the media question related to
all of this because mainstream media is
absolutely crumbling.
Everyone knows it.
Yeah.
When I was on with you on election
night,
what I kept saying was we've watched the
mainstream media slowly crumble as the
online media has risen,
and I think as of the election,
it's actually starting to tilt and now
the online guys are kind of winning,
which is why you're seeing all this
stuff about fake news.
Not to say that,
and some people online are a bushing out
fake news.
I get that.
They are,
but what do you think first of the,
of the meme of fake news,
it seems pretty obvious to me,
although I don't know who the full
conspiracy behind it,
that someone in power is pushing out
this idea because they lost control.
Yeah,
I mean,
I don't,
I don't think it's a conspiracy so much
as somebody says,
there's one story that comes out,
right.
And fake news and everybody sees is on
it.
Right.
Which is usually how I like being in the
right way.
Media works.
It's,
it's,
it's like,
it's a,
you know,
to sharks grom like it's,
it,
the,
the term is in the water.
All the sharks come.
So somebody says fake news,
they go,
ah,
that's a great excuse for why Hillary
Clinton lost because everybody believed
all these fake things right now
mirasee of basically lazy.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's exactly right.
And think that,
that it's,
again,
that's not to say there isn't such a
thing as fake news.
There is,
I mean,
there are a lot of stupid headlines that
glow around that are not true and that
we spend time to banking,
you know,
from the right and from the left,
things that things that are just
patently false.
Um,
and it's,
and trump himself was a rather large
promulgator of things that were false.
And it was important to try and debunk
those.
But the media had so shredded a total
credibility that it couldn't fairly
debunk any of this stuff because they
were saying things that were false were
true for years.
And then along comes trump and he
basically runs a post truth campaigns.
You have two candidates running
post-truth campaigns,
the media insisting that only one is
running a post truth campaign.
And then everybody going,
wait a second,
like you don't get to be the arbiters of
truth because you blew all your
credibility a long time ago.
Well,
the problem is that now no one's an
arbiter for truth.
So I,
the,
the media certainly wasn't.
So I'm glad to see them come down.
Yeah.
What I would like to see take its place
is okay,
now it's honestly analyze what's true
and what's not true as opposed to what
serves our interests in what,
what doesn't.
So The Washington Post called me
recently and they asked if you're trying
to determine whether a news source is
credible or not,
what are sort of some quick keys.
Yeah.
And I said,
well,
the easiest thing is are they open with
their bias and do they run stories that
counter their bias,
right?
If their,
if their news outlet and they only run
leftwing stories and there are left wing
sites,
they only run leftwing stories.
They never run a story that counters
anything that they say,
then you know,
you should what you should double check
for sure.
They're probably just a propaganda
outlet.
But if they're a site,
like I think the Washington Post
actually better than New York Times this
way.
The New York Times is entirely one
perspective.
The Washington Post not,
not talking bout their opinion
columnists.
I'm talking about the news that they
break.
Like the Washington Post is actually
breaking some anti Hillary News in the
past,
in the,
in the last three weeks before the
election cycle.
And so,
you know,
I think it's important to distinguish
those.
But um,
yeah,
I mean when there's no gatekeeper,
the good news is there is no gatekeeper.
The bad news is there's no gatekeeper.
Yeah.
It's not a full,
it's not a fully great thing because
nothing has emerged yet that act as a,
that and it maybe that's just because
we're demanding more of people,
but people have to demand more of it.
I'm not saying there should be somebody
who like,
I'm not the gatekeeper.
You're not there.
No one is the gatekeeper.
But I my own gatekeeper.
Right.
I analyze the news for myself and I
don't just believe every headline that I
see on facebook.
Yeah.
And that that I do think is a concern
because that's going to polarize the
news.
If you're just picking the headlines
that reinforce your bias.
Yeah.
Then you're in,
you're not likely to,
to achieve anything remotely resembling
the truth.
And it almost seems obvious that this is
where we were going to end up because
everyone,
this is what everyone does on twitter.
You cater things to yourself.
I try not to do that,
but every now and again,
something gets to me to the point where
we're like,
I cannot follow this buzzfeed,
my final Straw.
We,
I unfollowed them already before that
gains thing.
But I was like,
wow,
that's why I am followed this drivel.
But,
but even that,
there's a risk in that.
Yeah.
By slowly just filtering everything into
your own little ideology that
the best indicator is if somebody is
hated by both sides,
that's a pretty good indicator that
they're at least baseline honest.
Yeah.
Right.
That's,
that's,
that's like that.
There's a level of honesty.
And what I mean by that is,
is not,
you know,
people who are obviously conspiratorial,
but people who are flack from every side
because they don't please one side all
the time.
That's it.
It's not a foolproof test,
but it's,
it's an okay test for people who tend to
be more honest.
So you exist sort of in both worlds.
Do you consider yourself a more,
more mainstream than no,
I'm kind of straddle it.
But because you're on Fox a lot and
you're on CNN a lot me on that often
that because they,
because again,
I have the troublesome quality.
If not,
they don't know not,
I'm gonna say.
So it's,
it's a little bit of a problem.
It's hard for them.
A little.
They'll have me on like I'm on a Fox
News once every three weeks maybe,
and I'm on CNN once a month perhaps.
But I'm not like a regular guest on any
of these places.
So if they continue to crumble and if
the online thing grows,
and as you're saying when there's no
gatekeeper,
anyone's in,
and this is a problem now,
okay.
As you said,
it can be on us,
it can be on,
it should have us individually,
but most people don't have that real
risk there too.
People are lazy.
Right.
And that's,
and that's,
and so that laziness is going to apply
except there's not even a shred of,
of gatekeeping.
So that the problem with a lot of the
news that the problem with the fake news
critique is that it's encompassing a lot
of angles on the news.
So it's not that the news itself is
wrong,
it's angles on it.
It's like how politifact does their
analysis.
So politifact,
we'll say about,
Mitt Romney will say this,
I,
this happened during the campaign.
Hillary Clinton said something about she
liked open borders.
Trump goes on stage and says,
Hillary Clinton says she likes open
borders.
Politifact analyzes it and gives it a
half true.
Right?
And he's just repeating exactly what she
said,
but say,
I bet his implication was that she was
saying x,
y,
and Z.
It's like,
well now that's your calling his stuff
fake news,
but you're the actual fake news because
you're reading implications that you're
reading into him.
Uh,
once,
once you get into reading other people's
implications,
uh,
you ended up in some pretty dicey
territory.
But it used to be that when there was
actual fake news,
people lost their jobs,
right?
Like Jason Blair promulgated Fake News
and lost his job at a publication that
we on the right hate the New York Times.
Um,
but that's it.
There's a difference between that and
the angle on the news is wrong or the
facts of the story,
right?
And the angle is wrong.
That's not fake news that you don't like
the angle on the story.
Right?
And so,
but the left and the right trade,
it should recognize this.
Not everything that comes from the
Washington Post or New York Times is
false.
It may just be that the angle that
they're giving you is an angle that you
don't like or an angle that that doesn't
reflect underlying truth.
It's been out of the facts of the story,
right?
Yeah.
The facts of the story.
Right.
So when the New York Times reports
something like,
you know,
a,
when the New York Times reports a,
the,
if they'd reported,
uh,
the hands up don't shoot thing just
straight.
That's,
that's fake news.
If they report that a black guy was
killed by a white officer in Ferguson,
Missouri,
and then they went with proceeds to
report it as though it's a serious
problem all across the country.
The fake news part of that is their
angle.
It's not that a black guy was shot by
the white guy,
you know,
in,
in Ferguson,
Missouri.
And what I've seen is that people are
throwing the baby out with the bath
water.
So it turns out you can't believe
anything in the media says right now you
can't believe their angle.
You can't believe anything they say.
So if they say Donald Trump hasn't
turned over his,
his irs reports,
he hasn't turned over his,
his tax returns.
There's a tendency for people to say
that's fake news is we know that that's
not fake news.
That's true.
You might not think it matters.
You may have 10 excuses why it's stupid,
but that's not fake news per se.
When everybody just called stuff they
disagree with fake news and it's
happening now again on both sides.
I've never felt simultaneously less
bipartisan and more bipartisan about
life than I have in the recent past.
And then again,
that's where I think opportunities
because there's so much being reset
right now.
W what do you think about the risk of,
it's not coming from the government in
some ways,
censorship right now,
but we know what's happened with prager
u videos where they've put hard
restricted lists.
We've had,
I did an interview with John Mccain who
is on,
who was on cable news every single day
to decided to demonetize it.
I mean,
you know,
I did my interview with Ion Hursey.
I leave 80 monetized.
Uh,
we have all kinds of stories now.
If things getting hurt and algorithms,
even my low being banned,
I get it.
Twitter can do what they want.
Yeah.
So all of this stuff is starting to add
up to something,
right?
Like there's something cracking down on
this new wild west out here.
Yeah,
for sure.
And I think that you've seen,
you know,
twitter pay for some of that and in
market share,
it's going to be incumbent on people on
the right to build an alternative
structure to these things.
And that's very expensive.
And people on the right don't tend to
think in terms of media too much.
So we invest a lot of money and
politicians and we invest a lot of money
and think tanks,
but we don't invest all that much money
in media.
There are a few kinds of people who will
invest money in media,
but the number of like we gave $100
million to somebody to start a business
very low.
You'll see a lot of people who spend
like five to $10 million to start
something,
but to start an actual twitter,
you know that that requires enormous
expenditures,
the capital.
And most people on the right don't see
that as a winning business proposition
because people on the right tend to
think in terms of Roi and twitter hasn't
even seen an Roi,
right?
Whatever twitter is losing money still.
So it's,
and,
and also it's,
it's hard to go up against the behemoths
like youtube,
like there've been some attempts to go
up against against youtube before there
is a conservative attempt to go up
against youtube.
It didn't do particularly well because
the problem is that it was billed as the
conservative attempt to go up against
youtube.
It wasn't built as open to everyone.
And so you sort of have to,
to do the open to everybody routine in
order to really succeed.
But you're at it,
you artist systemic disadvantage.
Youtube has existed for,
for forever.
But again,
youtube is just what the New York Times
was 30 years ago.
The only thing in the space as,
as things progressed,
I think that you're,
I mean the truth is that youtube is just
a search service with a lot of big w
with a lot of servers that provide space
for the videos.
And I'm,
I'm old enough to remember when ask
jeeves was a threat and then Google
eight.
So or hotmail,
I mean like all the prodigy.
That's probably before your time.
Yeah,
exactly.
They're all,
all these things look insurmountable at
the time and then over time the market
destroys them,
right?
Aol was the big thing and now nobody
uses say,
oh well,
I mean the thing is,
look,
this show is on one of our,
our main method of distribution is
youtube.
So I want youtube to work,
I want to work.
So it,
and I think that it's,
it's,
it's a very interesting debate.
I will say it's an interesting debate
when people look at private companies
like youtube and they say,
well,
they shouldn't ban anything.
And it's like,
well,
you can make the argument that youtube
should ban certain things like a,
like a graphic terrorist video,
for example.
Should it,
do they have the right to do that?
Now for me,
I'd rather err on the side of everything
goes up,
then think and then certain things come
down because I don't really trust people
in charge of anything to to to do that.
This is why I'm more libertarian,
even when it comes to things like
youtube,
but I see the argument.
I mean not all,
not all forms of speech are created
exactly equal,
at least in their merit.
They are in there in terms of your right
to say them,
but they're not necessarily in terms of
merit.
And when you're in the private sector,
you're speaking about merit.
You're not just trying to speak in terms
of right to say.
Yeah.
Do you think there could be a first
amendment issue related to all this?
Now I get it.
It's
governor.
When people try and make the utilities
argument,
I don't think it's a particularly good
really,
because to me it seems,
it seems maybe not fully because we
don't know what a public utility,
if there's something else going on.
So it's not utilities.
But I would argue that the owners of
these companies,
the people on the board,
you know,
Jack Zuckerberg and all these people,
they are so intertwined with our
politicians right now.
Yeah.
That now we actually,
I'm not saying it's directly a first
amendment thing,
but there's something there because it's
almost collusion with it.
So I,
I agree.
And the,
and the solution to that is to downsize
the government radically,
not to,
not to have,
you know,
our guy do it.
Right.
You know,
that's it and that,
that's,
that's what I'm saying.
That's what I'm seeing generally is like
it's a,
it's our guy doing it so it's okay now.
But um,
but yeah,
of course.
I think that that Zuckerberg working
closely,
here's the thing,
Zuckerberg wouldn't be working with the
government if the government were
powerful.
Right?
Like if we,
we spend a lot of money on the
government,
we give money to political candidates.
We spend all of our time talking about
trump or hillary because the
government's powerful.
I think anybody spent tons of time
talking like in 1836 about,
about the national election.
I'm sure they spend some time talking
about it,
but it wasn't dominant the way that it
is now.
The idea that people were just,
they could be the most important
decision that I was.
People not dating,
right.
Destroying their lives because if who
won the presidency when it was Franklin
Pierce,
no,
nobody,
nobody was doing that.
This is part of the reason is that the
federal government just was not
particularly powerful.
So what do you care what some bureaucrat
in Washington DC is doing?
It doesn't affect you.
So that really,
uh,
I've said this a couple times.
To me that's the best argument for small
government.
Yeah,
I agree.
Which is if you don't like Hillary and
you don't like trump,
it's not,
well then I should vote for more
Democrats or vote for more Republicans.
These idiots out of our way.
Exactly.
And that's,
and that's the,
I think the only smart thing,
the repair,
he said in his presidential campaign in
2012 and you said you wanted to make
Washington dc insignificant in your
life.
I was like,
yeah,
that sounds great to me.
Yeah.
Because I said or anything else.
Yeah,
exactly.
I said,
I set it up.
I say this on college campuses all the
time on college campuses.
Kids are constantly thinking,
oh,
there's so many obstacles to what I want
to do.
And you see in politics now,
trump keeps saying there's an obstacle
to what you want to do,
and I'm the left.
Hillary says there's an obstacle and
I'll knock down all obstacles.
We're all gonna knock down all the
obstacles and they erect new obstacles,
right?
Yeah.
And it's in,
what I've always said is nobody gives a
crap about you.
Like no one cares about you.
No one sitting around going,
Dave Ruben,
I got to stop that guy.
How do I stop Dave rule?
But there's a couple of people there.
There are,
there are a few people.
That's true.
But as a,
as a general matter,
if you weren't even in politics,
if you're just a guy,
right?
Nobody would be sitting around going,
how do I stop Dave Rubin for becoming a
successful accountant right now?
Nobody is doing that.
And except that the government does do
that actually.
And so if we could apply that same
sentiment to the government like nobody,
it's none.
It's nobody's business.
What you do with your life,
leave me alone.
Solve your own problems,
right?
Those,
those few sentences in conjunction would
solve a lot of,
would solve a lot of problems,
right?
Solve your own problems.
Get the government out of your life.
Nobody cares about you except like you
and your family and your friends,
right?
Know nobody's actively plotting against
you.
I know that we all live in our own
little movie and we did.
We all live in our movie where they're a
great villains and you're the great hero
and we're all like this.
Every human being is like this,
which is why movies are successful,
but in reality,
how many people in a lifetime actually
have active enemies who are acquiring,
attempting to thwart their every move?
You know how many people just have like
the jerk of a boss?
He's bothering them.
Although oddly in our space now for
public people,
the idea of the enemies is growing.
Oh yes.
Yeah.
I get it.
For the regular person.
You know,
it would be nice to think that now you
say regular,
we don't mean like less than we just
people,
not politics.
Exactly.
I think people that are probably doing
much,
much more for the world,
but we are but,
but the idea that you stake out a
position now publicly and you
immediately have enemies.
I mean I see all the time now things
will be written about me that I know
were absolutely not true.
And they'll call me your far right
winger and they'll all of these things,
what I've said about this or that and
they misquote me or any of this or like
partial quote and it's like I could
spend the rest of my life fighting this
stuff or I can ignore it.
And I usually try to ignore it because I
got to live somewhere.
And again,
it's because of these topics have become
so intense because there is so much
control over how these things go.
And also when one,
when the government's very small,
everyone on the eye,
everyone on the inside is a little bit
fascist.
But I mean by that is everybody wants to
be the king,
right?
It's just you don't want anybody else to
be the king.
You want to be the king,
right?
You'll be the good king.
You'll be the one person in human
history has been an excellent,
excellent king who is always generous
with power and decent with everybody.
You're going to be too narrow,
storm,
boring.
You're just gonna go around breaking
chains and everything's going to be
spectacular and that,
and so as politics,
when politics was small,
that didn't matter because the best
thing you could hope for to be your own,
you know,
your,
your fiefdom was your house,
your fiefdom,
you're homeless,
your kingdom,
your fiefdom was your family,
right?
It was.
Those are the people you were,
those were your subjects and those were
your citizens,
right?
Those were the people.
You took care of a,
and now government is so big that you
actually have a shot at being king.
And when people think they have a shot
at being king or at least getting into
position a person who is going to be the
king for them,
then you're an obstacle to their utopia,
right?
It trump,
if trump is utopia and I'm not voting
for him,
I'm an obstacle to their,
you'd hope you have hillary is utopia
and she's going to be the great,
the great chain breaker and I'm standing
in her way,
then I'm an obstacle to utopia,
right?
Everybody either becomes,
as I've said before,
a tool or an obstacle to utopia.
If you think that utopia is realizable
on a political level,
if you don't think that you're a fool,
like one of the things that,
one of the things that I've,
uh,
I think there are certain areas where it
just in life you become more mature as
you get older a little bit and you see
more of this.
And one is that when you're,
when you're 18 or 19 or 20,
your utopian,
you think,
how do I solve this problem and this
problem won't be a problem ever again.
And then you read more history and you
deal in politics more,
and you realize there's never a problem
that actually goes away.
All the problems come back.
And it's just a question of,
can you push the ball a little bit this
way?
Can you push it a little,
a little bit this way in favor of human
liberty.
Can you push?
Can you,
can you push the looming disaster a
little bit further down the road?
Right?
Is that it?
And,
and when you do that,
you become,
you become a problem for people who want
utopia.
Because Utopia requires a lot of people
to be willing to sacrifice their present
for a future that doesn't exist.
Uh,
and that's,
that's a scary thing.
I think everybody's a little bit Utopian
now.
And that's,
that's everyone's feeling that on both
sides,
right?
Because you could argue that the trump
people are feeling it.
He's gonna bring all the jobs back to
Ohio.
All of them are coming back,
right?
He's going to make sure that we never
have a terrorist attack on American soil
again,
and he's going to do it with his magic
wand.
Right?
And he's going to do it by not trusting
the CIA or the FBI,
but still we'll get it done somehow.
We should pause there for a second
because what,
what are you making that we were just
for one minute.
I have no idea what to do.
So,
so yes,
I think Russia hacked the DNC.
Uh,
do I think that it exposed things that
were,
you see the evidence,
right?
Okay.
So was legit,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
the Democrats are basically acknowledged
that the contents of it were real.
They weren't making things up.
So I think Russia was behind the hacks.
And so I think that shaped the election.
Not really.
I think Hillary would have lost anyway.
And the,
I did a piece a few minutes ago about
this where I think that there's some
evidence to that effect.
One is that hillary is unfavorable
ratings.
In January of this year,
before any of the wikileaks stuff
happened,
her favorable ratings were,
I think it was 43% favorable.
Uh,
sorry,
it's 38% favorable,
56% unfavorable.
November 4th through seventh.
Right before the election,
she was at 43% favorable,
56% unfavorable,
so she did not move at all.
Right.
There was no point where she built,
she was consistently unpopular all the
way across.
It wasn't wiki leaks made are unpopular.
The big thing that hurt her in the last
couple of weeks was the comey thing was
the FBI director saying he was reopening
the investigation and that had nothing
to do with Wiki leaks that had to do
with Anthony Weiner's computer.
So it wasn't the wikileaks that actually
shifted things,
right?
It was.
It was a lot of other things,
but it wasn't the wikileaks per se that
that said,
again,
this is a case of shoe on the other
foot.
If the Russians had hacked the RNC and
trump loses by 80,000
votes in three states,
right.
Are we crying black or,
or be up in arms.
Oh,
right,
right.
Exactly.
Would we,
and would we be,
you know,
we have people on the right would be
crying bloody murder.
It'd be the end of the world.
Again,
the hypocrisy on both sides is pretty
astonishing.
I'm the on the left going,
although those evil,
evil,
evil Russians,
they're so evil.
I hate the Russians.
In 2012 Obama was openly saying caught
on microphone.
I want flexibility.
I can give flexibility to Russia if they
helped me out in this election cycle,
no problem.
That's fine.
Months of when Romney said they're our
biggest geopolitical foe and everyone
mocked him.
Right.
And and also within months of hint of,
of Obama backing off the red line in
Syria and within two years of him
backing off of the Ukraine stuff,
right?
And so they didn't care about Russia for
years ago,
but now they care deeply about the
threat of Russian on the right.
The same people going,
Russia's our major geopolitical foe in
20 [inaudible].
I don't see the problem with gluten.
Well why?
Why can't we be friends with Putin who,
how's this?
How's this a problem?
And say,
my goodness.
I mean if,
if your,
if your belief switch that fast,
I'm going to go with you really had not
a lot of core.
So to me because I can't really figure
out what the actual truth is.
I don't think anyone really knows that.
We haven't seen the right out of the
question is do you believe the CIA and
the FBI or do you believe self motivated
people on both sides?
Although right now it sounds like the
CIA and FBI aren't even in complete
agreement on what happened.
They both do agree that the,
that the Russian sources were behind the
attacks,
they just don't agree on what the motive
was.
Right,
right.
So the FBI says it was to undermine the
election integrity and the CIA says that
it was to get trump elected.
Yeah.
Given trump's position stated positions
on Putin,
which were incredibly warm throughout
the campaign,
I don't find the CIA's claim
implausible,
but again,
their motives doesn't,
don't matter.
Bottom line is did they shift the
election?
There is no evidence they did.
So the reason I guess I'm a little more
skeptical is that if,
let's say we really knew it was true at
some,
that this was true technic,
wouldn't that basically be an act of war
at this point?
If,
if Obama knew right now,
if the FBI or CIA came to him that this
actually happened,
they were in cahoots with trump or
whatever it is,
you would be an act.
I mean either way down sanctions or some
sort of military,
I mean that would,
that would be a true undermining of our
democracy at the highest levels.
So the fact that we're not talking about
that,
not that I want to be a war with Russia,
I would be completely again against.
Right.
But the fact that it's not getting to
that level shows me that this seems like
more of a game or political showmanship
then something that's real.
It also demonstrates a massive increase
in partisanship.
And the reason I say that is because go
back to 1972 and Richard Nixon is
bugging the Watergate Hotel and an
attempt to get information about
mcgovern.
Right.
And he's swamps mcgovern.
It's pretty clear that he didn't need to
bug the hotel in order to get the
information.
Matt mcgovern to swamp them make up the
winds like two states.
So,
and then he's impeached by row
Republicans.
Republicans are getting,
and he's not technically he retires,
but he's about to be impeached by
Republicans.
Or Republicans are going to impeach him
for that.
Now you have a foreign power doing what
Nixon did write the exact same thing and
they bugged the DNC,
right?
They,
that's the,
that the allegation and nobody on the
right cares and nobody on the right
care.
It's like,
it's,
I don't think that has to do with,
you know,
people aren't taking this seriously.
I think that one of the questions is
just,
all right,
how happy are you that they did it and
when the question is and,
and so I think that there are a lot of
people on the right guy.
Well,
it's good they did it.
I don't mind that they did it.
I mean,
after all hillary had it coming,
that's like that.
So didn't mcgovern kind of in the sense
that the government was awful,
but that doesn't really change the
activity.
Well,
isn't the other piece of this that if
this all happened,
doesn't it show ineptitude at the
highest levels of our current
government?
I mean this,
not that Obama in self would be making
decisions related to this,
but you'd have to fire almost everyone
at every security service.
And then at the DNC,
right,
everybody was responsible for the,
for the security of the DNC.
Yeah.
But it has been government agencies
apparently there,
there's some hacking of government
agencies has been going on for a while
and the word cyber war with,
with China and we have been for a long
time.
Um,
yes.
I mean the government,
as I've said,
socks at virtually everything and the
solution seems to be more government
from both sides.
Now the year of small government is over
and the,
the,
the idea that the government is going to
shrink in any margin in any measurable
way,
I think is,
is fallacy.
So on the history repeats itself for a
long game idea.
There is opportunity here,
right?
Because let it get big so that people
will ultimately see that it does not
work.
And then,
and then the era of small government may
be can come or do you think is right and
get to a tipping point where you just
can't come back.
Yeah,
I mean I,
I do think that you get to a tipping
point,
but it sounded tipping point where you
can't come back.
It's a tipping point where we actually
hit disaster right here,
the Greek tipping point where at a
certain point you must hit the austerity
button because otherwise your country is
absolutely bankrupt and then you get
riots in the streets.
And so the question is how,
how ugly are things when reality sets
in?
Because the reality is you can't keep
affording to pay for all of this stuff.
Eventually one of two things happens
either wise up or you go bankrupt like
California's about to do when things get
really ugly.
So it's,
so the question is which one we head
toward and the fact that a lot of the
gains of sort of the Buckley,
Reagan conservative small government era
had been put behind us in favor of this
bigger government nationalist populism.
That's not a good sign that we're moving
in in the wising up direction.
It's actually a sign that we're moving
in the opposite and that word that we're
kind of now,
okay,
fine.
The government's peg,
we except the government's big.
What can the government do for me today?
Yeah.
Um,
and that's,
that's a,
that's a problem.
This is why like people were very
intense during the campaign.
Conservatives saying,
Mike Pence,
trump selects him.
Isn't that great?
They're very enthusiastic about the
pens.
Peck.
And I was like,
yeah,
Mike Pence seems good.
And then you've got my pencil now going
around to rallies with Donald Trump is
free markets here saying that he's okay
with tariffs and saying the free market
fails when it's tried and from going
every time,
every time.
And it's like,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
Hold on.
That's very sick coming from trump.
Okay.
That trump's been saying that stick the
whole time.
But like pence rally good.
At what point until we,
as I say,
we're not going to see,
you know,
really where the Republican party lies
until the first conflict between trump
and the republicans.
Like,
are there enough republicans who are
going to stand up against him?
I don't think so either.
And I think the trump has building
machine outside government in order to
take down the ones who do.
Right.
He's,
he,
he has Kellyanne Conway building this
uh,
this apparently this machine,
it's going to seek to push his message
outside government and maybe primary
people who,
who don't grant him the leeway.
So
such a sad state of affairs because it's
like we've never needed a strong
independent fourth the state more than
this.
That's right here.
That functions properly now and it's
exactly what we don't have.
Yeah.
Well this is a,
I've been saying this now for several
months and I was thinking during the
Obama era too,
is that it was clear that the country is
ready for a demagogic fashion efficient
stick leader.
Cause they just want something done.
Right.
That's the fascist.
Like people,
the Word Fascism always brings to mind
Nazis and Jack boots and all this stuff.
But the truth is that most kind of,
most dictatorial governments don't start
off that way.
Most of them start off with,
we have a breakdown in the political
system.
We need somebody to do something right
now.
Right now there are too many pressing
problems.
Get somebody in there to fix it right
now.
And if you look back at history,
most dictatorial governments don't start
with the ultimately bad dictator.
They start with a couple of educators
who actually are not quite as bad,
right?
If you look at it like Germany,
1930,
1932 you're looking at at people who
actually aren't that bad,
right?
You're looking at it bruning and you're
looking at it on paper and you're
looking at a bunch of people who,
uh,
who are I hurt people who are like
basically not terrible,
awful human beings,
but the centralize all the power here
and then the next person who sweeps in
is the bad guy,
right?
So whether you think that Obama was a
bad guy,
whether you think trump is the bad guy,
once you bring all the power to one
place,
once you've created the,
once you forged the ring of power,
then it's only a matter of time before
the bad guy gets ahold of the ring of
power.
Unless you destroy the ring of power.
Because you'll have a bunch of people
who are seduced by the ring of power.
But eventually somebody bad we'll get
ahold of eventually he'll bring a power
will make its way back to sal Ron.
So you may think that trump isn't the
guy who's the threat,
which is fine.
Maybe he isn't.
You know,
I assume that he isn't because I don't
really see that we necessarily is.
Maybe you think Obama wasn't the guy.
Maybe you think that Obama wasn't the
true threat to American democracy and
liberalism,
but once you've got this much power in
one place,
somebody will be,
somebody will be elected at some point
who just says,
screw all of the norms.
Things have to get done.
The trains have to run on time.
Right?
It's not only
that,
it may not be the guy you like,
it could be someone heard,
it could be somebody.
Really.
That metaphor was pretty good,
but can you get that into a star wars
thing?
Is that possible?
Can you get that into some?
Well,
I mean,
there were no real good way to destroy
the dark side of the force,
right?
Yeah.
So in,
in it's,
it's not quite as,
it's not quite as good,
but everybody is,
everybody has to do so well.
Like when you're a kid,
everybody wants to be darth Vader,
right?
Yeah.
When you're a kid,
nobody wants to be Luke skywalker.
Everybody wants to be darth Vader,
darth vader.
As much cooler,
you can strangle people,
but his mind,
right?
I mean,
like he can relate to it.
It's much cooler.
There's only one problem,
which is that you also have to build
this enormous staffs starting below
planets.
So eventually the powers,
right.
I'm in.
Come on.
Alderaan screw those guys.
Lauren.
Screw those guys.
All right,
one more for you.
Shapiro.
Uh,
because I get this tweeted at me a lot.
People say,
Dave,
you should run for president in 2020,
but on the second part of the ticket,
Shapiro
number wine,
you'd show people that bridges can be
built,
blah,
blah.
Would you ever go into politics?
I'm not in California.
Uh,
and,
and given the way that our current
politics is going,
it seems like only celebrities can be
elected.
So,
um,
well you'll have that part down.
I mean,
you have your following.
That's,
yeah,
but it's,
you don't have to be,
it would have to be a lot larger
following than that.
Right on that necessarily.
It's,
uh,
it's something that,
that I could see doing at some point.
Um,
yeah,
2020 is a little soon.
Uh,
it's a,
but yeah,
I'm,
I'm not averse to the idea of,
of running for office at some point,
but it depends on whether you can do
more good outside of government.
You're inside government,
especially when you want to destroy the
instrument itself.
Uh,
so is it not just read the entirety of
the government to destroy a lot of the
power of it?
Uh,
and
so it sorta could never in a way you'd
suffer from.
Although I know you don't.
I'm telling the truth with a little bit
with Rand Paul and a lot of stuff.
Um,
you'd suffer,
you'd suffer [inaudible] policy by the
way.
I agree with a lot of what Ram I'll ask.
Right.
But,
but I know in foreign policy and some
other things,
but you would suffer from the same thing
that he suffered from,
which is I'm the out,
I'm trying to make this thing smaller.
You're even if you're all conservatives,
you're still trying to make it bigger
for the party.
Can't really rally around you cause it,
it doesn't really fit the way people
think.
Yeah.
I mean I think that
to benefit from backlash politics,
you have to have,
as you say,
there could come a point where
government is so big that people are
actually willing to hear a message of
solve your own problems.
Screw the government.
These people have,
have destroyed lives and power
centralizing in one place is not the
answer.
Um,
but you know,
people will have to be convinced of that
because until then everybody has the
everybody on the inside,
once that ring,
everybody inside,
once the,
the dark side of the force.
And so,
uh,
my job right now is the same as yours,
which is tell people the Truth and hope
that they awakened to the fact that your
life is in your hands.
Um,
and if it's not in your hands,
then we need to,
we need to change the system so that it
is in your hands and people aren't
taking things away from you or promising
you things because the promise is just
another way to take something away from
you.
Sometimes it's your,
your actual,
uh,
your,
your actual self control and self
esteem.
Uh,
somebody makes a promise to give you
something and they're taking something
away from you too.
Nothing is,
nothing is free.
So if you want to be totally self
sufficient,
then we need an actual place that that
allows self sufficiency.
Nothing's free.
I thought if you,
if someone gives you something,
it's free.
You mean that someone else is paying for
that?
It's right.
It turns out,
yeah,
I see.
I have to do it.
It's that inability to understand that
may be screwing all of us.
Yeah.
Guilty liberal.
Exactly.
All right,
well it was a pleasure talking to you.
It was great.
Great to be here.
And our,
uh,
your office is not that far from my new
student.
Yeah,
that's true.
So I suspect we'll be doing a lot more
of these crossovers.
I think we could,
you know,
2020.
I just,
I really,
I just could never be president.
I could be vice president.
Well,
it's a,
it's a cush job.
I mean like,
yeah,
he just sit there and you go to like a
nice house and
I've yet to meet Joe Biden.
Yeah,
I'd be very good at that.
I just,
I feel like you'd be much better in
terms of the big anyway,
uh,
for more on Ben Shapiro,
follow him on twitter at Ben Shapiro.
I tried not to send him Nazi memes if
you could.
Uh,
but again,
if you do,
if you do all frame them,
put him on my wall,
you know,
really just take pleasure in them and
enjoy them.
Yeah.
And I know he won't ban you,
so there you go.
That's true.
All right.